you know i know we have several people
in the hot breath that are interested
in getting into um late night and so i
know that's been
been one of the big questions we do see
a lot is
how do i start that process of getting
into late night writing
well first of all i think it's a you
know it's a daily thing right you find
you get on you look at your news app or
you get on get online
find your regular place you go for that
news source
and um you start to look at the
the headlines that kind of resonate with
you that that trigger an emotion
and eventually you'll be able to
identify some that you know will truly
trigger an emotion with your audience
like you know i mentioned like if
there's anything about tom brady um
people love him or hate him
and there's going to be you know if
there's a story about tom brady people
will pay attention
and they'll now if you can then write a
joke about it it's gonna it they'll be
more involved than if it's just the
general
you know idea now it's one thing to just
have
relatability or recognizable or
something that's familiar
it's another thing that have people that
are either that are fans because when
they're fans
that's a big that's a big emotion which
is why trump is
so often used in late night you know we
write what's in the news
and trump by design makes sure he's in
the news every single day
so who do you think we're going to be
writing about so when people get upset
about you disrespecting the president
really dude i was i was on staff at leno
when they were making fun of uh
bill clinton for like 12 years after
monica lewinsky
uh it happened and it was still going on
so and i wrote some of those jokes so
get over it you know but i think the
thing is like
you got to start writing the goal most
of these writers write 25 to 40 jokes a
day
um so that you know what you're that
threshold that's expected of you
um then once you're once you're good at
it
there are ways to reach out that are
kind of
built around the system uh one of the
things i would suggest to people
is um do a youtube you know build up
your fans my friend charlie
my student charlie behrens he has the
manitowoc minute
and it's a niche character he's from
like this wisconsinite that don't you
know
and he's got the he wears like a camo
windbreaker and he's up
in a hat and he just does he does local
and national news
but only for about a minute and 35
seconds there's this little quick thing
he does some relatability to wisconsin
some local stuff
some national stuff quick jokes nothing
really too offensive
just you know always keeping his
eyebrows up and you know keeping it
absurd as opposed to negative instead of
going like this and getting
you know judging people's ideals so he
went from when i first found out he was
doing this
a it was last september october he had
77
000 subscribers at youtube and he was
selling out rooms
of fans during one night he sold out
flappers main room
four o'clock in the afternoon on a
saturday who sells out a comedy club
four o'clock in the afternoon on a
saturday
right i was blown away i went to go see
it and then talk to him afterwards he
goes i'm just doing what you told me to
do
you told you when i asked in class how
do we break through this i said get a
niche character
you know develop a social media appeal
keep it short and tight
and then people will start to identify
with the character
and but he even man he's got them
reminiscing about where they used to
live
all that stuff they want to come back
now he's at i think 150
000 subscribers that's great on youtube
in less than
a year and um now he's you know he's
doing some other
things he's selling product he's selling
merch and
people love this character and his jokes
aren't that great
but the character is great and so we
love the jokes through the character the
jokes themselves mechanically you go
but the character sells the jokes so
that's like a sitcom in a way i have a
feeling this guy is going to have
either a special or a sitcom in the next
two years
you know because that character's so
like likable
but if you're doing something you're
putting out really quality material
every
chance you get two or three times a week
eventually somebody's going to take
notice
if your numbers start and you stay
consistent your numbers really start to
go up there
and you know if he hits half a million
if he hits a million
um he's going to get a deal right so
that's one way that's outside the system
the other way
is when you're getting good and you see
you're writing 20 to 40 jokes
consistently
usually 25 to 40 40. and you're putting
out good content you're
running by your friends your friends are
going hey man that's some really good
stuff
i would listen to you but you got to
make sure you're getting good advice
then one of the things to do is to
follow the credit crawl
on what shows you're targeting and maybe
think about targeting two or three
and follow the credit call in the credit
card you're going to see
a title called supervising writer and
supervising writer is usually the head
writer
then you'll find that you you can look
at the bottom of the credit crawl and
say oh it's filmed over at cbs
uh or you know most of them are in new
york
called the production office of that
show and even if you just call the main
lot and you say um i'm looking for
conan or i'm looking for kimmel or i'm
looking forward to both these are in la
um i'm looking for stephen colbert's
show
um then they say we'll put you right
through or else you get this phone call
production
then you just say the name of the person
who is
william dadfree hey bill dadfree
yes speaking hi jerry corley you've
never heard of me
but you know i'm a writer i wanna
could you take a moment and share with
me what specifically you look for in a
submission package
and then they're like if i'm a writer
and somebody called me
i go dude's doing what he's supposed to
be doing that's cool
kudos to him and i would take a moment
but if i was in a super hurry i'd say
hey can we do this another time i'm
slammed
i and i'd call back 30 times just until
he picked up the phone again
you know and but is it's polite
persistence polite persistence polite
persistence
never take no as a no never take a hang
up as anything but
hey we're busy um if you stay persistent
you will get better and you'll break
break down that door there were eight
people that
quit there were eight jobs that could
become available in late night tv
just this during this last six months
that's
a huge number people deciding you know
what they're they're
now good time to retire or retire early
or
move on or do whatever whatever their
motivation
anytime something happens like that
that's opportunity right so
if you stay persistent and you keep
writing you keep writing as if you have
a job
your job is to get the job your job is
to have us have material ready for the
pitch
that's not even happening right now but
it will it'll be that opportunity
where uh somebody says hey send me a
packet or i would just send in packets
randomly and find some creative way of
doing it
you know um so it takes no this case you
know like for example
if i was bugging the head writer and i
already got a packet written
all i have to do now is tweak it to what
spec specifics
they gave you they gave me and
and it's just a little tweak and they
say yeah well i look for this this this
and this
and if it was in la i would get on my
word
uh and tweak it then print it out put it
in an envelope
call a messenger have the messenger
deliver it right over to the production
office
that day like three hours later he gets
a packet from me he'll go holy [ __ ] who
is this dude
you know that's impressive so that's
another way now not everybody has that
opportunity
you can overnight it or something do
something different
but you got to stay consistent that's um
it's a challenging level to be you're
working with a lot of guys who are good
at this or a lot of guys and gals who
are good at this
but they're always looking for new
talent
if i'm a head writer my job is to make
sure my host has the best material make
sure i've got the staff with the
most creative writers uh that come up
with good content
if they're not producing i give them a
little kick in the butt if they don't
work
if they are still not producing like i
need them to produce then they're
probably going to be let go
and then so i'm always looking for
somebody good if you're consistently
sending a material this guy's got great
shitty right so yeah prolifically
and you've always got some stuff coming
in
that opportunity may arise and
you also find different ways to get
their attention
one of my students she went goes to the
seminars
at the television academy
of arts and sciences they have these
seminars and often have
like conan will speak or colbert will
speak
and she'll go to them and she's in a
wheelchair she just rolls right up there
and says hi you know and introduces
herself gets a picture with them tries
to give him a tape
and talks to them about how you get on
the show as a comedian
she's breaking the rules man and meeting
people and handing him packets
so it's just a matter of find out where
they're making personal appearances
you know i had my uh my my friend lou
mojellowitz
uh from vegas a comedian he um
was in one of my workshops he goes how
do i do that i go you got leno
shows right up here at the at caesars
every friday night
so why don't you go down there have a
packet ready with a bunch of monologue
jokes
and uh go to the state find out where
the stage stage door is
go to the stage manager and see if he
can deliver it to leno
and um waiting out in front of the stage
door was bobby slayton
he sees this packet this comedian
looking dude walking up with a pack he
goes
you got a packet of jokes for jay don't
you he goes yeah he goes i'm on his
plane with him i'll hand them to him
personally
and he did and two months later lou gets
a call from leno
you know and then um uh he he said what
do you want do you want to be a comic do
you want to be a writer he goes
i want to be a comic well i can't use
you then i said dude what you you want
the job right you said i want to be like
you jay i want to do both
um you know and then you say to him i'm
not getting off this
if you're on the phone with a decision
maker you say you know my job right now
is not to get off this phone until i
have a job writing for you right
you know that's that's the purpose right
now and so they'll laugh at that because
nobody asks for the job
yeah they expect somebody to just hand
it to them if you're serious about
becoming a comedian
join our facebook group linked in the
description below to start getting tips
like these every single day
and watch this playlist of our top
writing tips to improve your writing
today